max Greenfield good to see you sir you
too sir how are you I'm very well you
know Cedric I have met him a couple of
time has he never been on the show we
got to get him on uh he'd be great I
mean did Cedric the Entertainer throw
out the first one the Dodgers had two
people throw out a first pitch one day
yes yes I was one and then said to the
other yeah you guys did it on the same
day yeah and then when Cedric you know
we recently went and saw he got a star
on the Walk of Fame and Magic Johnson
gave it was one of the him and Magic
Johnson George Lopez introduced him and
magic gave his beautiful speech they've
been friends for a really long time and
one would think that we would be able to
get Laker tickets because of it and even
LeBron Trump's magic at this point now
Cedric a second Cedric the Entertainer
despite having Magic Johnson introduced
him yeah at his Hollywood Walk of Fame
at aramony nothing zero nope Wow yeah
well I mean maybe wait last year last
year you it's it's like a you know it
would have been a revolving door oh my
god choose your seats good seats still
available I mean that's you know I was
funny I was on a podcast yesterday
someone was asking me about how LeBron
is playing out here I think LeBron
coming to the Lakers has even even
overshadow the Dodgers making a World
Series a second straight year I even
believe that that more and more people
are talking about LeBron maybe then the
Dodgers
you seem to be having an issue with that
I think if they weren't Owen 3 yeah I
think I think expectations like oh okay
I see what's happening here and not to
say that that won't turn around it
probably will but I think right now
people brought that because there was a
sensor in preseason wait a minute oh
they couldn't be like unbelievable right
and now I start but I mean the Western
Conference is so good but now you get to
see Iowa all right they're gonna be
fighting for maybe a seven get Barkley
Barkley was saying on opening night at
halftime of the Trail Blazers Lakers
game that the the pace of play that the
Lakers are on right now there are
running the floor the transitioning
they're trying to get easy buckets are
trying to get layups that to do that in
the Western Conference is gonna be
completely different than Eastern
Commerce even think LeBron could keep up
that pace over 82 games
I never said it's crazy it's great they
also they look small they just look
small and then you got like well the
Marcus Aldridge certainly made him look
small the other night whispers so are
you from here are you from here in Los
I'm from I'm from New York we're in New
York
you're from Westchester okay yeah so
that's why you were a Yankee fan I was a
Yankee fan I'm a stench max what the
hell so growing up I was big as big
Yankee fan how old are you man I'm 39
okay I had a gold my first goldfish that
my parents got me as like this is what
you are to be responsible for I named
him Dave Winfield I think this is Dave
Winfield the goldfish yet they wouldn't
feel to go Dave Winfield lasted about
two an aspect to go belly-up it was May
of 1981 is when they went belly-up
no it's October Roberts number to call
to mr. May well you weren't even you
know and I'm not sure what year was it
was somewhere in like the early nineties
I think and you know we had that team
where was Jeter and Brosius like Paul
O'Neill and Martine ISM we were watching
the playoffs and I remember it was just
at a time where I was like young enough
where's old enough to sort of be with
all my friends we were watching the game
we were in the playoffs and we were
playing the A's and it was when Giambi
was on the A's when GE yeah and it was
yes and it was the best and I remember
never being more fired up about a series
and games in my life and then the next
year Giambi is in a Yankee uniform and I
I couldn't make sense of it
so we're what happened to the Dave
Winfield goldfish owning I cook Mac
screen I don't know what happened I
couldn't make sense of me is what caused
you to yeah a hundred percent up the
show and then and then it was Giambi and
it was sort of like one of those moments
like a Keyser söze moment where you're
like in a box and Clemens mhm and then a
rod at some point you're like hmm what
have I been doing this whole time and I
really like I turned on them a little
bit and now I'm
and it's the saying it's so now you're
out yeah man I won't pull you back in
yeah Alan judge is not pulling you back
and he's exciting but no can't do it
sort of like turn to the Dodgers a
little bit well we're out of time
and now jumped on the Dodger you kind of
IED your team
I'm not Reggie Jackson hit four I know
you're too young for the Reggie Jackson
3 home run I'm not really a baseball fan
now until late September okay look now
there's your you're busy man I don't if
you have to have kids I have two kids
you're raising them as one uh this is a
good question I only ask those max we
got I take my daughter to Los Angeles
Kings games so we good we've gotten into
the Kings exciting and I was never
really a hockey fan but we have a good
time there
I love LeBron so we're gonna sort of do
the the Lakers but weren't we're Nick's
family see now I was about six
I left the Knicks like you left the
Yankees okay all right my moment because
I felt like you judged the move and now
I'll no no no no no no I definitely
judged you were correct in picking that
vibe up I judged and I hear you I Aaron
judged okay I'm also right about what
I'm about to say about the neck okay
okay it's the same way you felt about
Jason Giambi yeah now suddenly becoming
us what was your Giambi moment my Giambi
moment was Charles Oakley getting his
ass dragged out of Madison Square Garden
the mouse was in jail while the owner
sat with his scarf and his coffee cup
and he wasn't bothered to even stop what
was happening and that was after all of
the nonsense that was going down with
Isiah Thomas and all the craziness with
Phil Jackson I'm gonna get banned from
WFAN but not Knox doesn't pull you back
in Knox not doesn't pull porzingis did
okay I pulled me back in and then Oakley
got pulled out
yeah and I'm and I'm still and porzingis
almost got traded which thank God didn't
happen because yeah Jackson still had
his hands on the wheel
one last draft before they fired him
hold on a minute after after they let
him draft they let him draft and then
got rid of okay well he went played the
harmonica with his schmucky band there's
birds Oh norm oh by the way there's real
hope right now though
be careful by the way I know you're a
fantasy a football player yeah that was
gonna be on one of our team names that
we have a team together with Dolan
wormhole that's when you mentioned James
Dolan I go right down it and ISM right
off it's tough it's bad
I just got spun I'm sorry you're a guest
do you think the necks have a legitimate
shot at a real free agent next year yes
somebody's gonna I think somebody I
think I think some how many I've said
that somebody's gonna take Dolan's money
and I'm hoping it's Kyrie Irving really
yes Wow cuz that busts up the Celtics
okay
and it's exactly what the Knicks need
some guy from Jersey who knows what it
means to play in the garden who respects
it despite the fact that the man who
owns the place disrespects everybody
that walks in there I'm never gonna be
allowed in that building I don't care
you can keep cold in your tongue cuz you
want to go in your bill no I feel really
Bertie that loves the Knicks won't like
I know they won't say uh the fella from
from Simmons his group network network
why am i blanking on his name oh yeah
okay he was tweeting back and forth with
uh with our buddy uh Ferrara Jerry
Ferrara
oh yeah Jerry's a good buddy Jason
concepción was tweeting back and forth
with Jerry Ferrara about the Knicks and
I jumped in about Dolan and as soon as I
mentioned Dolan Ferrara was out got two
courtside seats still gotta get out
Jerry our seats okay Jerry's Jerry look
Jerry's big in the organization he said
he has the the Drake is he the Drake
roll I I think quietly I mean he's not
really betrayed by his spike is the guy
over there do you know Jerry runs
they're like video game League he's the
manager of the next video game League he
can't be kicked out of it he's on the
payroll
[Laughter]
how are you enjoying doing the
neighborhood with Cedric Cedric the
Entertainer the best man it's like a
real old-school
I mean you as it's an old-school
multicam which is really nice and I
think like nada not a lot of them exists
anymore
in front of a live studio audience my
studio audience it's not really a joke
based comedy it's really situational and
there's like they the writer Jim
Reynolds who created the show has really
allowed it to have these real moments
and we are there isn't necessarily a
joke at the end they don't let the
audience off the hook and you get to
really know these characters and it's
been so much fun
yeah and said what's it been like with
Cedric the Entertainer I mean he went
out I mean he goes way back here in Los
Angeles he knows everybody and yeah he
really is like oh he really is a legend
and just knows everybody and and has so
many of his people like Ray Lewis came
by the set the other day like there's
just what all these like people that
just will roll through Ray Lewis yeah
ray came through it was really cool he's
a big dude he is he's bigger than you
think right could you imagine him in
pads coming at you downhill at you he's
got an enormous head so like I had a
buddy of mine who played middle
linebacker at UMass and he was and he
said that the Scout he said Scouts came
up to NFL scouts came out to him and
they said let me look at your hands and
he was like wow and he showed him his
hands and they go oh no you're like 70
pounds more than you should be and he
was like am I at the time I was he had
like beefed up just by looking at his
hands cuz they could see that his hands
were disproportionate to the rest of his
body and then you see some of these guys
like Ray Lewis and I remember I met
Lance Briggs and you're like these guys
are freight trains they're like the
wheels fit on the train if the you know
we were talking about this the other day
about Urlacher when you meet Urlacher he
is way taller than you think he is
McGinest
willie magnus hood Urlacher story this
this is now of the floor is yours so
this is many many years ago this is when
it was bald yes totally and who's he he
was young bear okay we were doing
celebrity ins this is when NSYNC was
still a group I was like by the way they
they still are a group I guess so we
were did but this before Timberlake went
solo so we were in Chicago they invited
me out I was on Veronica Mars at the
time and they invited me out to do some
NSYNC basketball game it was in Chicago
so Urlacher was playing in the game and
you could tell once it sort of start
like once they they tipped the ball this
guy like just doesn't know how to go
half speed mm-hmm and there was some
drummer from some band like some poppy
you know thar ban got in the way he was
going for a loose ball and her locker
thought I got a chance of this this guy
mowed down this poor drummer from
whatever an internal tap in a way that
was every like teen girl who was sitting
there going oh my god mercy man play
basketball was like horror and you could
see her locker her locker got the ball
like knocked it back in bounds and you
could see like it was just there wasn't
any sort of recognition that I had just
murdered a pop star on the side of court
well he gets why he's in the Hall of
Fame max it was a knows one speed it was
really cool to see well it's been cool
hanging with you here I am greenfield on
Twitter check out the neighborhood with
max Greenfield Cedric the Entertainer
and and more Mondays on CBS at 8:00
Eastern Time come back appreciate good
luck to you and your fantasy football
season from here on out that's max
Greenfield here on the Rich Eisen show
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience